let me jump to this story from the Daily
Mail quote it rips our wounds wide open
family of capital cop Brian sicknick who
died the day after January 6 slammed Fox
News and Tucker Carlson for using new
footage to downplay Riot and claim his
death was not Linked In the video
footage I don't know if they have it in
the article actually it looks like they
do let me uh we'll uh we'll mute this
real quick and then we'll play it
you can see officer sicknick is walking
around seemingly uninjured doing his job
telling people to move he walks over and
he grabs some sign of some sort and then
puts it behind a statue so he's going
about his business they initially
claimed the New York Times that what did
they say that he got killed when a fire
fire extinguisher hit him in the head
that article is still up right now in
fact let me see if I can
see if we can find it
New York Times I I had the archive there
we go I saw it today here it is there it
is
he dreamed of being a police officer
then was killed by a pro-trump mob yo
this is definitively proven false how is
this article still up right now because
they're lying Liars look at this they
have an update that's all they have new
information has emerged regarding the
death the capitol police officer Brian
said like the questions the initial
cause of his death provided by officials
uh so how about you take down your fake
news well or leave it up but but make it
very apparent that this is an old
article that's been changed in the title
that that update should be in the title
well you guys are asking for way too
much this is that is unrealistic that is
never going to happen it stopped
happening seven years ago this is like
liberalist slander felonious like from
yeah back in the day
a mob can't sue you right they have
defamed a a pro-trump mob as they've
described it right they haven't
identified anyone exactly they're like
we didn't burn anyone we just fed the
fire so that's that's for all you who
are wondering how to defame people and
get away with it apparently just apply
them to a group so say like a group of
philiban was seen punching a dog or
something and it's like I didn't say he
did it I said a group of him was doing
it yep
then my pronouns are they apparently
they so I guess here's the thing man
you're gonna no matter what happens no
matter what proof it's as Yuri besmanov
said you can show the demoralized person
proof and they won't accept it Ian just
mentioned I think you're mentioning it's
easier to fool the person or is it as a
Mark Twain quote it's easier to fool
someone than to convince them that
they've been fooled the reason the
reason is fooling someone is is a simple
task of putting your trust in the wrong
person but telling someone they've been
fooled is to insult their ego and it
makes them re-calibrate their entire
world view on the spot it's a challenge
depending on how much you know depending
on how much they have to recalibrate
their world view if someone has a deeply
a deep conviction from when they were
like a kid ripping them out of them at
30 years old is going to be nine
impossible 100 but if somebody like
walks down the street and sees a dog do
a backflip and then you show them proof
that it was actually an Illusion by a
magician with a mirror they're more
likely be like oh I didn't realize that
and like if they've told 50 of their
friends that a dog did a backflip
they're going to be less like they're
gonna be more resistant yep realizing
they're a liar it's not just a one-off
anymore you're right it's probably more
than seven years ago but this has been
an ongoing campaign of disinformation by
the mainstream media I mean go back if
you go Russia gay Ukraine impeachment
one two Jan six the CCP balloon to bring
It full speed and then you talk North
stream too all of these people have been
lied to and lying in the media
consistently even though they were
proven wrong coveted Origins I was the
deputy director of National Intelligence
when we briefed Trump where the virus
came from and you know what he did the
next day band travel from China we we're
all Races four years later hey do you
guys know where the covet virus came
from the Wuhan left no
s but all those people
were lied to by the New York Times for
years and years and years think it was
somehow Trump engineered or related to
his you know ineptitude that we have
coveted on on planet Earth and this is a
carryover that they are able to just
forget and say okay what's the next
what's the next iteration of fake news
we can come up with so just speed
through what we were duped on so we have
a couple different types of people in
this scenario people on the left who
know it's all a lie yeah but are lying
themselves because they feel they're on
the right side of history or they don't
want to fight or for whatever reason and
the people who genuinely are just not
smart enough to ever see through this
and they just keep going on and
believing it which do you think is
bigger which like the stupid action okay
ignorant people I should I shouldn't be
so cruel I should say um
incapable of of discerning is it a lot
is it like 60 40 I don't know man you
know there was uh who's that comedian uh
Bill Burr is that his Bill Burr bald
dude yeah he was on Rogue and he was
like look Joe I I don't I don't know I
just turn on the TV they say put in The
Mask I put a mask on I just uh two weeks
later take it off I'll take it off like
that's the kind of person that's voting
Democrat they say I don't know I don't
want to know I'll turn the TV on and do
whatever they tell me to do at the time
so it's it's it's it's maybe I should
add a third person the people are that's
that's probably the people who know
they're being lied to don't care just
tell me what to say and I'll say it
because I want to go eat you know a
pizza at the bar with my buddies or or
watch football or something I don't like
not only you're right but I don't
there's I feel like most people are so
busy with like the real important things
of in their lives we do it here we talk
about how families are important we talk
about how you know go get away from the
cities that you know go have chickens
all that all the stuff you know meet
real people and at be active in the real
world one of the things that comes with
that is the responsibilities and that
means that you don't have the time to
sit there and be up to date on it and
it's it's a balance is I guess is what
I'm saying yes but Joe Biden gets
elected and you look at the charts and I
understand we're we're in the know the
the economic charts show that wages drop
dramatically right after the time Biden
starts signing these executive orders
and the uh what is it wages drop in
inflation skyrockets this means there
should be a real world translation that
we all know about that should be
impacting regular people to realize
things are bad that is under Donald
Trump or before the pandemic the best
numbers of Our Lives record low
unemployment the economy was booming it
was tremendous everybody agrees then Joe
Biden gets elected and you can't get
eggs
no no eggs anywhere now you're I don't
expect the average person to be like let
me go on my phone and look up why
there's no eggs I expect them to go to
the store and be like yo where the eggs
at something's wrong or why do they cost
so much when I can't or why are they six
bucks like what's going on something
inflation something's crazy but here's
the issue these people like do they not
remember 2019 do they not remember
making tons of money and having cheap
goods and going out and partying best
numbers of Our Lives they forgot it all
it hasn't and now with all with
everything being bad you mentioned like
we're in the know but certainly there
should be economic dissent there should
be families being like why is my rent so
high why are my insurance rates going up
the it hasn't hit them yet though
because there was there was so the
inflation is still going up just the
other was yesterday the Fed was talking
about uh they're not gonna they're
probably not gonna lower the uh interest
rates the next time they get together or
they're probably going to raise them
again because inflation is not going
down as fast as they want a lot of the
reason why people aren't up in arms is
because the squeeze hasn't hit enough
people and it hasn't reached that
critical mass not saying it's not coming
it's just that it hasn't really got to
them yet I really don't think that the
average person has the real like the
real pinch where it's like oh man I
really need to stop complaining about
this and really get up and go do
something or else I'm not going to be
able to feed myself or whatever I don't
think that that critical mass is hit yet
yeah that's the frog in the pot boiling
scenario and they I have heard this lull
security false insecurity where they say
it's Putin's War that's causing the
inflation so I think people think if we
can just weather this inflation once the
war ends it'll go it'll be over yeah I
mean there's probably still people that
believe it's transitory that's one of
the things that the government has been
had been telling the population for a
year leading up to inflation getting
really really bad oh it's transitory
don't worry about it it's only going to
be short term every time that we that
inflation was brought up for the past
two years or past year or whatever the
the
Administration has downplayed it and
done its best to probably responsibly
keep the population from freaking out
but at some point they have to
acknowledge look it's going to be it's
not going to be as easy as it's not
going to be a soft Landing we're gonna
probably go into a recession probably a
serious one and until that happens I
don't think people are going to be like
oh you know things actually are bad what
do you think from a national security
perspective about inflation does that
concern you is it one of your when
you're big it is one of the non-sexy
items from a national security
perspective is inflation if everything
costs more than the defense of this
country costs more but the problem that
we have is we just print money to the
defense industrial complex and I'm not
saying as a former Chief of Staff at DOD
who paved the way for one of those
budgets and wrote a lot of those
contracts and funded them I call the
five big CEOs of Boeing earthwork
grumming and all those major producers
that we have McDonnell Douglas and I
said okay look a lot of the stuff you
make awesome provides an invaluable
asset to defend this country and a ton
of the stuff you make doesn't I've
literally seen you light billions of
dollars on fire so how do we strike that
balance right and that's the problem
when people don't know what inflation is
and then they just say oh it's a
trillion dollars who cares if it's 1.1
trillion no one ever actually really
cares and the people that care the least
are the defense industrial Compass
because they take the check back home no
matter what win or fail and to me that
is something that whatever whoever's in
the next Administration if you don't
agree to take on those monsters in the
defense industrial complex it doesn't
matter what the inflation numbers are we
are going to print money into a
never-ending cycle I also see inflation
affecting domestic security and that you
get roving bands of hungry dudes and
masks that go into restaurants and kick
kick tables over and grab stuff like
that's security we need individual like
local security as well which is a form
of Nano National Security the
Groundswell that concerns you talking
about you saw the video that yeah
another one today of like 14 dudes and
masks just wrecking a place in New York
and yeah oh I'm not opening fire for
some reason because it's New York City I
mean what is this what is the story let
me pull it up it was it was it was just
a video that I saw and obviously Ian saw
there was just a bunch of dudes just
ransacking this this establishment uh it
looked like it was Asian owned I don't
know uh I don't know any details I only
saw the video I don't know who it was or
whatever I'm not pointing fingers or
whatever but that's not that's not it
but how do I search for it I don't know
I don't remember who it was that that
posted it but it was another you know
essentially just another uh video of of
people just ransacking Andy Noe might
have it lawlessness I typed in mob to
search
real life version of The Last of Us
maybe thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time